in the 21st century machine learning is
rapidly becoming an integral part of
everyday life every month there are huge
advances in the field of artificial
intelligence and machine learning and
especially in the field of image
sciences anytime you are dealing with
images there is so much the machine
learning has to offer
and previously almost unimaginable tasks
like like turning a static image of the
Mona Lisa into a movie are now possible
with some of these techniques for
machine learning so this begs the
question how much of this technology how
much of machine learning can actually
carry over into the physical sciences
and engineering and in particular in my
field of engineering fluid mechanics I'm
Steve Brunton and I'm gonna walk you
through how machine learning can be used
for fluid mechanics in a number of
vignettes and examples so this is a huge
field absolutely massive progress
happening in machine learning for the
physical sciences for dynamical systems
and especially for fluid mechanics where
we have such vast and increasing amounts
of data from simulations and from
experiments and so I'm gonna walk you
through at a very high level some of my
favorite examples and applications of
how machine learning is being used for
fluid mechanics today good so I want to
start by kind of just walking you
through what I think of when I think of
machine learning especially applied to
engineering systems so fluid mechanics
are absolutely everywhere fluids play a
central role in nearly every
trillion-dollar industry health defense
transportation energy we literally live
and work inside of a fluid and so do all
of our machines ok and most of the tasks
that we have in fluid mechanics for
example model reduction or getting
reduced order modeling controlling those
those fluid flows figuring out where to
put sensors to measure them and closure
models to reduce the complexity these
really critical fluid dynamics tasks
will
important in solving many of the
technological challenges of the next
century so if you think of any
science-fiction vision of the future a
lot of that is going to be enabled by
advanced fluid mechanics models and
controls so better energy systems better
transportation systems you name it again
fluids are going to be playing a central
part in that and what I want to point
out is that all of these tasks or almost
all of these tasks in fluid mechanics
can very naturally be written as hard
optimization problems okay so these
optimization problems and fluids are
very challenging that's why it's hard to
make progress in these fields that's why
they're so important these optimizations
are nonlinear non convex multi scale
very high dimensional but I want to
point out that that is exactly what
machine learning is getting really good
at so if I want a pigeonhole or kind of
make a blanket statement about machine
learning I'm gonna say the machine
learning is building models from data
using optimization or more generally
machine learning is a growing set of
techniques for optimization for really
high dimensional non convex
optimizations based on a growing wealth
of data ok so machine learning is
optimization with data and most of the
problems that we have in fluid mechanics
can be very naturally written as
optimization problems so these go
together extremely naturally and what
we're gonna see is that lots and lots of
techniques for machine learning can be
directly applied to solving these fluids
optimization problems like modeling
control sensing and so on and I want to
point out when I say high dimensional I
mean that the fluid flow itself has many
many many degrees of freedom I might
need a million or billion degrees of
freedom to simulate a turbulent fluid in
a computer so it's very high-dimensional
it's nonlinear because it's governed by
a nonlinear partial differential
equation the Navy or Stokes equation and
those combined to make these
optimization problems very non convex so
there's tons of local minima in these
optimization problems but again we're
gonna use emerging techniques in machine
learning to start kind of gaining
traction in these fluid dynamics tasks
and I want to point out you know machine
learning is not magic a lot of a lot of
people who are not kind of in machine
learning research or have a background
in applied math or statistics you know
when I talk to business leaders
oftentimes our initial conversations
they think the machine learning is like
you know a Harry Potter magic wand and
you just have a problem and you point
your machine learning at it and it
becomes solved and that's not at all how
this works okay so this is really
important to dispel kind of this myth
that machine learning is magic this is
very understandable in terms of linear
algebra optimization and statistics and
I think this is really important we
can't let machine learning become a
black box where it's indistinguishable
from magic and so to that point we need
not just machine learning solutions in
physical sciences and in fluid mechanics
but we desperately need models that are
interpretable and generalizable models
that we can understand and communicate
and work with and models that we can
trust will work even in new situations
that we haven't seen before and so
instead of kind of rigorously defining
what I mean by these I want to give you
an example so I think of Newton's second
law F equals MA as the ultimate
interpretable and generalizable model
okay its interpretive all because it's
very simple there's only you know it's
in terms of force mass and acceleration
and it's generalizable in the sense that
Newton can discover this law from an
apple falling on a tree on earth and
this law still works when we design
rocket mission from the earth to the
moon okay so this model is interpretable
and generalizable it covers a range of
phenomena even phenomenon oftentimes
that we hadn't seen before okay so this
is what we want in our machine learning
models especially when we apply these to
systems in engineering like fluid
mechanics where they might be
safety-critical where it might be a part
of a system on an airplane or in a car
okay and I love this quote you've heard
me say this before or quote quote
Einstein before everything should be
made as simple as possible but not
simpler and this principle of parsimony
or if simplicity is one of the
is that we promote machine learning
models that are both interpretable and
generalizable and so mathematically what
we're looking for oftentimes are models
that are sparse so they only have a few
terms like F equals MA or e equals
mc-squared low-dimensional so they're
not in terms of a million degrees of
freedom like a fluid my dynamic
simulation would be and we want them to
be robust in lots of ways robust to
noise and disturbances robust to bad
information that goes into the training
and robust to new scenarios that we
haven't seen before
okay so this is what we want in a kind
of machine learning for fluid mechanics
in general now I want to point out a lot
of what I'm going to talk about in this
video and in in future videos related
are following this review paper that I
wrote with Barrett Nowak and Petros
Kunitz aqus on machine learning for
fluid mechanics this is in the annual
review of fluid mechanics from 2020 and
you can download this paper on the
archive so here's a figure that didn't
make it into the the review but I like
this this figure a lot and it kind of at
a very high level points out that fluid
dynamics generates tremendous amounts of
data so we have theory simulations and
experiments that are kind of generating
this fluid dynamics data and machine
learning can be thought of this as this
common information processing framework
so that you can integrate this flow data
and use that to start solving these
really hard optimization problems
in modeling and control and reduction
okay so this is really critical is this
kind of common framework to understand
all of this fluids data and just a point
of history I think this is kind of fun
so so Barrington Petrus and I started
working on this review together actually
we had separate conversations about the
history of machine learning in fluids so
it turns out that fluid mechanics is one
of the kind of old and original fields
where machine learning grew out of so
fluids has tons of big data a lot of
computational architectures and
algorithms were developed specifically
to handle fluids problems and in this
example it this is kind of a neat
example that shows that a lot of these
concepts in optimization and stochastic
optimization actually go back pretty
are in fluids so in the 60s and 70s in
in Berlin Reichenberg and sh Zweifel
kind of pioneered the use of
evolutionary algorithms or genetic
algorithms to design and optimize better
flow systems so in this experiment they
have this multi panel plate where you
can change the angle of these plates and
they were trying to find an optimal
configuration that would reduce the drag
on this configuration and so running an
optimization that included some aspects
of stochasticity so this is AG Alton
board or Galton brecht which is
basically a Plinko game if you like the
prices right you drop a little ball in
here and it bounces around and if you
sample from this distribution of where
that ball falls it's effectively
sampling from a binomial or a Gaussian
distribution and they use that to
introduce stochasticity into their
optimization so they did some kind of a
stochastic gradient type descent to find
an optimal configuration and in in the
end it actually turned out not to be
exactly flat which is really interesting
now you should read more about this
history it's it's pretty neat and there
was kind of a debate at the time about
how this fit into the larger field of
fluid mechanics research was this fluid
mechanics research and increasingly
we're finding today that kind of these
optimizations and flow physics you know
they're very tightly linked and so the
field of fluid mechanics is
intrinsically linked to data driven
optimizations there's also this really
nice connection this to this kind of AI
winter in this video by by Sir James
light Hill and so I think I'm just gonna
play this this is Sir light Hill
essentially holding some of the leading
AI researchers at the time in the 70s on
trial so he his argument was that
machine learning and artificial
intelligence had gone through this
massive hype cycle they had been hyping
and hyping and hyping the promise of AI
how it's going to change everything
speech recognition natural language
processing and that research had
fundamentally failed to deliver on these
promises and so this trial and his
subsequent report the light Hill report
actually was a pivotal
played a pivotal role in the so-called
AI winter that really resulted in a
massive cut in funding for decades in
artificial intelligence research it's
kind of ironic and Petros pointed this
out I think this is really funny that
one of light Hill's criticisms of AI was
that it didn't deliver on natural
language processing and here we're
watching this YouTube video that is
being automatically transcribed by a
computer algorithm so something has
changed in the last twenty thirty years
a lot of it is based on better
algorithms better computational hardware
and open source frameworks where you can
actually start to integrate these
algorithms and data easily and
efficiently and in a community kind of
reproducible setting okay so so a lot
has changed since then and were able to
do a lot more than we weren't before so
I'm gonna walk you through some
vignettes just kind of highlighting
areas of applications that I see machine
learning being super important in fluids
research and then later we'll do kind of
deeper dives into into these topics and
again this is very shallow this is the
tip of the iceberg there is tons of good
out work out there that I'm I'm not
covering right now but in my perspective
on kind of fluid mechanics in general
and this is with or without machine
learning one of the things that makes
fluids interesting and beautiful to
humans and and somewhat tractable that
gives us some hope that we can model and
control these things is that patterns
exist even in very very complicated
flows like this flow this cloud flow
over r-e shiri island at japan there are
these big dominant patterns or coherent
structures that resemble much much
simpler flows that we can actually model
and simulate and control quickly and and
robustly this is a picture from a review
paper by Sam Tyra and co-authors in the
AIW journal from 2017 I think this is a
really nice review paper that talks
about kind of how patterns exist in
fluids and how you can extract them and
this this basic theme of patterns
existing is one of the major entry
points of machine learning into fluid
mechanics and in fact I would say that a
lot of machine learning research really
is aimed around
either extracting or characterizing or
utilizing low-dimensional or dominant
patterns in big data like image data or
flow field data and so a lot of that
carries over very directly if you think
of your flow field as a picture and if
you think of the time evolution of your
flow field as a movie of moving pictures
then a lot of machine learning carries
over directly okay so one of our kind of
go-to algorithms for for pulling out
patterns in fluid flows is the proper
orthogonal decomposition this is
basically a principal components
analysis done on flow data where you
take a movie of your flow field this is
just flow past a cylinder at low
Reynolds number 100 and if you subtract
off the average flow field and do a
singular value decomposition or a
principal component analysis you find
that you can very efficiently represent
this fluid flow as the sum of only a few
kind of eigen flow fields or these these
proper these large amplitude principal
components okay so patterns exist you
can pull out those patterns and you can
get a much much simpler representation
of your flow so instead of needing a
million degrees of freedom if this was a
megapixel image I might only need 10 p
OD modes and how they vary in time okay
and so this idea that there are low
dimensional patterns in fluids allows
you to do really really powerful things
essentially take algorithms directly
from image processing and apply them to
flow data so this is work by Isabelle
Sherrill who's a PhD student working
with Brian Paolo G and myself and in
this example what she did was she took
that low Reynolds number coherent flow
past a cylinder and added a ton of salt
and pepper corruption so each pixel has
a random chance of being completely
corrupted not additive noise but like
just you know blacked out essentially
and using these algorithms from robust
statistics these kind of modern
optimization techniques that leverage
patterns and the data she's able to
decompose this flow into the true low
rank component that's characterized by
only a few PID modes and all of that
salt and pepper noise so she's able to
split the data into kind of the clean
data that we want
and all of this salt-and-pepper noise
and this is really very interesting you
should check out her paper there's a lot
more examples and details but we think
this is particularly interesting and
important for experimental flow
measurements so a lot of fluids are
still characterized in laboratories
because our computers just aren't
powerful enough to simulate all of the
degrees of freedom of flow past a
submarine or a jumbo jet and so we do a
lot of laboratory experimental testing
but those experimental measurements
might be quite noisy and they might have
lots of kind of TV static and a-looking
noise on top and so Isabelle's algorithm
or her adaptation of this robust
principal components algorithm allows
you to clean up that experimental data
and get much higher fidelity flow
estimates so that's one area where where
machine learning can be used is by just
leveraging those patterns and the data
as if they were sequences of images
another kind of area where patterns
exist is in kind of getting closure
models for very very very complex flows
so this is one of my favorite
simulations by my colleagues at kth in
Sweden where they're essentially running
this massive massive boundary layer
simulation so this is an extremely
computationally expensive simulation of
a turbulent boundary layer and what you
see here is that there are these massive
massive separation of scales so there's
little small scales these kind of
horseshoe vortices they're rising up out
of the fluid but then every time you
zoom out you see more and more and more
kind of structure and detail across this
incredible span of length scales and
time scales and this is common in all
real world turbulent fluids so flow over
a wing or over a boat or a car or in an
engine over a windmill blade you're
gonna get this kind of turbulent
separated structures over this range of
scales but again there are patterns
again it exists there are large scale
structures that matter for drag and for
lift and for mixing for efficiency and
so we might not want to characterize
every single degree of freedom in this
extremely expensive simulation but
instead we might want to get a reduced
order model for how the big energy
containing structures work together to
change the drag on this this boundary
layer for example okay and so this is a
classic picture for anyone who studied
turbulence this is the Kolmogorov
turbulent energy cascade which basically
shows that if you have a turbulent flow
you're going to have this massive scale
separation so the x-axis is basically
spatial scales on a log plot so big
vertical structures are here on the left
little teeny tiny vortical structures
are here on the right and real-world
fluids might have many many many orders
of magnitude of scales both in space and
time and so instead of resolving all of
this which is very expensive for
computers this is why we have the
biggest supercomputers in the world are
often built to solve these problems but
instead of modeling all of these scales
is it possible to approximate how these
small scales affect the big energy
containing scales that we actually care
about because these are often what we
care about for a lift and drag and and
things like that and so this is a
massive Field called closure modeling
and it's really really important it's
been a focus and fluids research for
decades and there's this great review
paper by DeRosa me yeah Kirino and Shou
called turbulence modeling in the age of
data where they really dive into how
machine learning and data-driven methods
are being used to tackle this closure
problem and I think this is one of the
most exciting areas where where kind of
machine learning research can really
make a practical impact on actual
everyday industrial flows and this is
just one example from one paper this is
one of my favorite papers on the topic
topic of Rands modeling this is the
Reynolds average navier-stokes modeling
where you need to close this model to
account for small-scale and fast terms
that you don't want to resolve fully and
so what Ling and colleagues did was
instead of just using the big deep
neural network which would be the most
obvious kind of first thing you might
try
what they did was design a custom deep
neural network with these additional
tensor input layers that essentially
allowed them to encode or enforce prior
physical knowledge about fluid flows so
fluid flows are not just unstructured
images or movies we know that there's
physics there's conservation of energy
and mass and momentum there are
symmetries and what they were able to do
in this paper was embed some of those
symmetries and invariants invariants
directly in their neural network so that
their simulation or their closure is
physical by construction and I think
this is a beautiful example of what we
all should be thinking about when we
apply machine learning to physical
systems is how do we bake in prior
knowledge to make it so that our models
are not just accurate but they're also
physical okay so really great paper you
got to check this out it's a classic in
the field now okay so other areas that
are really important super-resolution is
a technology that is really big in image
sciences and of course we can apply this
directly to flow fields if we think
about them as images so this is data
from the Johns Hopkins turn turbulence
data set and if you train on a large
collection of images like these in a
movie flow field images then you can
take very low resolution or downsample
versions of the flow field and
reconstruct kind of this super
resolution high resolution image with
all of the flow details so this is
closely related to that closure problem
is the super resolution problem again of
taking either low resolution data from
experiments or maybe this is a fast
cheap and dirty simulation and being
able to kind of fill in the details by
leveraging a large offline training
database to give you the statistics of
what flow fields actually look like very
cool emerging field lots of work being
done here and I'll just point out this
is so important I have to I have to tell
you about this this image I'm showed up
here I've shown up here that gives you
this beautiful almost perfect
reconstruction of the flow field from
this low resolution and down sampled
image that's what happens if you run
this super resolution algorithm as an
interpolator okay so what that means is
these kind of dark gray columns are
where you train the data and we randomly
pepper them throughout this movie so
time is evolving in this movie and we
randomly pull frames of that movie to
Train this algorithm and then we test it
on this test frame which is at one of
these blue locations that's kind of
between data we've already sampled and
so this is fundamentally an
interpolation task because this blue
column is kind of closely related to the
two images right before and right after
it in the movie that we're in the
training data but if we do an
extrapolation task and this is much more
realistic for many flow problems like if
you wanted to use this to predict the
weather in the future how the you know
the flow field around planet Earth will
look next month or next year that's a
future extrapolation problem so in that
case you'd be using all of this as your
training data all the past and you'd be
trying to predict the future and this
extrapolation is much much harder so you
can see here these are the truth flow
fields on top and as you start to
extrapolate forward and for farther in
time the first snapshots actually pretty
good but as you go further and further
in time you get terrible degradation in
the reconstruction so huge caveat
extrapolation is always hard and you
have to add more physics to make that to
make that work okay that's a much harder
problem you have to be careful about if
you're interpolating or extrapolating
good so we already talked about how
peyote and proper orthogonal
decomposition can be used to great
advantage to decompose a flow field into
its dominant patterns and decades ago it
was actually shown that this kind of p
OD or principal components analysis
could be written as a shallow kind of
one hidden layer auto-encoder neural
network so you can do this principal
components analysis in a neural network
frame framework and what's really nice
is that you can then generalize or
expand that neural network to have many
many many hidden layers and nonlinear
activation functions so you can build
these deep autoencoders that give you
much much better signal compression and
reduction so you would have the input be
your high resolution flow image or flow
field and in the middle layer
these are kind of the latent variables
or the dominant coherent structures and
then the decoder would use those few
variables to reconstruct an estimate of
the full flow field image so this is
kind of an information bottleneck that
compresses and then decompresses your
your flow field and I'll point out that
milano and Kumud sockets in 2002 I
believe were the earliest to apply this
concept to fluid mechanics in a really
really great paper I think that was way
ahead of its time
people are now you know two decades
later in full force trying to apply
these auto-encoders to fluid they had it
in 2002 so go check out that paper okay
good you can also use these concepts to
build reduced order models so once you
have those patterns extracted through
either P OD or an autoencoder
let's say for the flow field then you
can get very very simple representations
for example in those low dimensional
coordinate systems in those autoencoder
coordinates the dynamics might behave
very simply like they might live on this
parabolic Bowl this is what Barret Nowak
showed in 2003 and then you can use
these coordinates and use data-driven
methods like Cindy the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics to
build very very efficient models for how
these modes evolve in time purely for
measurement data and there's a lot of
great work on this
jean-christophe Lazo from Paris has been
innovating a ton of cool methods for
applying this Sindhi method to fluids
problems to enforce known physics and to
get really accurate and efficient models
of complex flow systems okay good
so maybe kind of one of the the last
applications of this once you have your
models and you've extracted your
patterns one of the ultimate goals is to
actually control your fluid you don't
just want to understand it and model it
you want to manipulate your flow and so
flow control is not this this is what
people think about a lot of times is
kind of again magic you could to
magically manipulate what your flow does
and that's not at all it happens this is
a very principled optimization of your
flow field and of your control law with
some objective in mind okay and again
those objectives come from the real
world I want to
increase my lift I want to decrease my
drag I might want to increase mixing in
a combustor okay and so those are all
optimization problems so there's nothing
magic about this and these optimization
problems can be solved increasingly well
with tools for machine learning so I
really like this diagram from a paper by
katarina beaker and Sebastian pipes
which basically shows that if you have a
really really complicated flow system
and you want to control it
instead of using the full Navy or stokes
equations which are far too expensive
what you can do is you can use machine
learning to build these surrogate models
that are fast and accurate and fast
enough to use in real time for feedback
control so this is a really nice diagram
that you can use for lots of different
types of machine learning models and
lots of different types of control
algorithms in this case they're using
model predictive control and I guess
maybe one of the last things I want to
point out is that much of what I'm
talking about in machine learning and in
fluid modeling and control is truly
inspired by from biology so a lot of
machine learning came out of wanting to
understand how biological systems how it
brains and nervous systems work so
seamlessly to make decisions and
understand and interact with the world
and in fluid mechanics we have some hope
that we can actually interact with and
understand and model and control complex
fluids because biology in some sense
provides proof by existence that it's
possible to interact with these very
very complex turbulent flow fields so
this Eagle is performing incredible
accurate or let's say agile and adept
maneuvers with out measurements of the
full three-dimensional flow field
presumably without knowledge of the
navier's stokes equations or any
advanced degrees in fluid mechanics the
eagle is taking measurements on its
wings and it's experience it's it has
learned to interact with this flow field
in an extremely elegant way that really
goes far beyond what we can do in
engineering systems and even beyond the
Eagle I take great inspiration from
insects that fly and lots of us at the
University of Washington are actively
working on
trying to understand how insects measure
and interact with complex flow fields
because they have very very simple
nervous systems compared to an eagle all
flying insects have strain sensitive
neurons on their wings and they use this
information to make estimation and
control decisions about what to do in
their flow environment extremely
fascinating learning systems okay and so
we want to know how we can learn from
them in our in our engineering machine
learning for flow control okay good so
that was kind of a very high-level
overview of how machine learning can be
used for fluid mechanics I'll go into
more detail and kind of go into depth
and some of those vignettes later but I
really do want to point out that so much
work is being done in this field this is
just again the tip of the iceberg in in
the future you should check and see what
has changed even you know six months
from now I guarantee you there will be
new technology that that I didn't know
about when I was making this video so do
go check out the references and and stay
tuned because this is an incredibly
interesting but also very important
field of machine learning research thank
you